now our crop is finally starting to
exert itself it's within a week of
Maximum tillering so it's it's growing
quite strongly now and a lot of those
gaps that we've had to live with for
several weeks are finally starting to
fill in so we're feeling
better uh this week we're going to take
the opportunity to talk about uh what I
would call the biotic influences on the
crop and making an assessment of it so
that's how uh animals plants funguses
and viruses how how they're interacting
with the crop both beneficial and not
beneficial and I have with me here Nancy
Castillo who uh who is a specialist in
assessing uh rice crops for for the
biotic influences and the level of
injury that's coming from it and Nancy
and I will will step through the process
of
assessing the rice crop for insects for
um for weeds for and for diseases both
from viruses and funguses so uh in we go
so next week what we intend to do is
that we will be collecting data on
injuries caused by animal pest animal
pest uh uh refer to insect pest snails
and rats and then we will be also
assessing injuries caused by diseases um
viral disease bacterial diseases and um
um fungal diseases and then we will be
also uh assessing uh injuries caused by
weeds this this is direct seated rice so
we have here a quadrat what we call as a
We call we we consider some kind of a
magic weapon so this is equivalent to
one heel and transplanted rice so
we we would actually be sampling
um for for diseases and insect and uh
and uh insect injuries we will be using
um 10 quadrants we be sampling from 10
quadrants and then we would be also uh
taking uh um we will be sampling weeds
from three areas each area would be
about 1 M by 1 M so we would be
assessing weeds relative to the height
of the canopy and we will be recording
the type of weeds that we will find uh
next week so we have a sweep net yes
this is a sweep net we use this for uh
counting the flying insects in this case
mainly Green Leaf
Hoppers uh Green Leaf Hopper is the
vector of tongro for the topping method
we have this small a pan here with water
it has a little detergent and we use it
for counting sacking insects like uh
plant Hoppers white back plant Hoppers
Brown plant Hoppers and in other in in
the surveys we do in other parts of the
Philippines we also catch rice bugs okay
okay um black bugs rather black so so
with these these magic
weapons week when the crop reaches the
stage of Maximum tillering you'll make
an assessment uh according to our our
data sheet and then again uh in the
reproductive stage in in the grain
filling and mature mature stage uh we'll
make another assessment that should give
us a good idea of what biological things
have done uh both for and against our
our rice
crop as the crop gets into maximum
tillering it's it's really doing its
thing the the photosynthetic synthetic
engine is really starting to power the
rice crop along
unfortunately Akim I and the local
rodents are deepening our relationship
and they've emerged and uh are damaging
the drop and use so whilst most of the
field is is filling in nicely we're
still getting getting gaps in the crop
and those gaps do seem to be
multiplying uh we're doing our best to
control the rats around the field at the
moment as per our regular program here
at irie but uh these holes are
irritating to say the least so we'll go
out and have a look at one of them it's
it's complete
damage
eating the rice off at the ground
completely killed the rice plant and
rendered an area somewhere between half
a square meter and a full square meter
completely bare or pretty well
bare they're quite selective they didn't
even eat the weeds which was a bit a bit
annoying um I can now appreciate how
rodents can completely decimate a crop
um Grant described to me the typical
pattern where they'll completely destroy
the inside of a field and leave the
borders intact which is a good deceptive
way to do your
work um I'm hoping we can stop the
emergence of these new new bear areas
from rats we'll just have to work our
hardest and uh do our
best